there's another one here there you
are welcome
back what's going on up
there what's happening up there we got a
few things to do we need to do fizzy Faz
nights number this we got a few more
mini games to do and then we're out why
am I over here
whatever right okay
so I'm just going to
scooch
everybody all right double caffeine
double acid oh crap doesn't even need
salt what am I doing ah well
shoot ow God damn it it's not that I
have a tiny office it's that this is
assuming I have a bigger office than I
do I'm going to fail this first one
because it can't be freaking bothered of
which oh God you know what it's fine I
can bring this back what did you just
fill and why is this still too close I'm
trying to be over I'm trying to be here
there we go okay we got this okay you go
on a break yeah I know I know I know
okay salt salt salt protein acid put
that in Slam that down you go there you
go to break you go here what I put acid
in there God I'm I'm not doing this acid
sugar okay just go okay let's see uh
caffeine needs to take a break uh it
better have that it better have that
acid well it did God damn it okay but it
needs salt I need salt
immediately oh crap protein acid oh
shoot there's no way I'm going to get
enough salt there's no way hurry up salt
I'm not going to get enough one two
three are you kidding me I got enough
Okay Candy going on a break cuz I'm
about to oh we just lost the
caffeine God damn it ah crap okay uh
sugar damn it you going to break Uh crap
crap basket crap basket yeah hi what's
up yeah you need to go faster you need
to go
slower sugar caffeine caffine salt come
on I know I know I know not make this
NOA here we go yeah I I got you he you
loud and clear crap oh that's not good
okay why is everyone want salt hey salt
can you uh
go there we go salt salt salt protein
protein put it in got it okay I'm still
not going to get this this is game over
but I did that at least ah you're on a
break why are you on a break well this
is a
problem uh uh but what if I conveniently
lock it down before that happens haha
you can't get
me all right that went off to a bad
start it's not my fault though because
nothing ever is my fault when it goes
wrong it's only my fault when it goes
right which is another way to say that I
did okay and no one can criticize
me no one so we're just going to scoot
the one we need which
is salt obviously salt
then we're going to rotate everyone out
salt acid protein two more salts pending
you're on a break you're going on break
you're going to speed up see you're
going to speed up because we need a lot
more salt than we currently have but
then after we get this you're going to
go on a break there it is and you're
going in there and you're going on a
break and you're actually going to speed
up because I need more salt and then
coffee is going on a break
next caffeine caffeine acid sugar sugar
okay that's all done need coffee to go
on a break need salt to still hurry up
need more protein I hate you so much I
hate you so much I hate you so much
don't you give me anything please don't
do anything don't do anything ah you did
something okay yeah I know I know okay
what do you need okay salt is going on a
bre Mast what is it okay salt salt salt
acid protein Wham go get out out of here
coffee's going on a break you're going
to be next Triple protein protein
protein protein was that three yes it
was acid sugar pop boom Oh I didn't need
to do that why did I do that that early
everyone except
caffeine you're going to go on a break
next o never mind we're
good okay leave that you go there salt
and protein protein needs a break cuz
for oh wait no that's fine
wait I don't know which one's pressed
which one was pressed okay whatever
lemon needs to go on the break and oh my
God oh my
God that's
fine good Lord she better be actually
gone after that I don't know why that
occurred uh we need lemon on a break we
need sugar on a brush we need you on a
rush we need nothing else
caffeine can well you need a break after
that okay you got a break that's got
time you're dead you're
Chica and then Wham okay so that's going
in we need salt on a break hi what's up
hey how you doing SC yo unless you got
some fun orders for me why is sugar not
cranking I need sugar okay we got sugar
okay that's good okay you're going on a
break you're cranking you're cranking
you're cranking you're cranking oh oh
God go on a brick oh god oh no hold on
you going on a brick Oh my God please
have acid and protein oh my God yes as
it as it protein slam that down caffeine
and
sugar okay that's good to go everybody
happy I'm still going to send them on a
break because apparently I can salt
needs to
cool this is fine that might be the last
order actually uh let's see what happens
I'm running ahead of what I need
so damn okay we got another one okay
salt salt salt acid protein I'm going to
just send that in because we're doing
fine you need to break sugar needs to go
God damn another one okay protein
protein protein acid sugar pop it in
what oh come on are you kidding me
really oh my God okay ah crap why why
did that happen protein protein protein
acid sugar pop it in go hi go away oh
caffeine needs to stop protein needs a
break you need to shut up and go away
you're on a break you're going on a
break okay salt salt salt protein acid
caffeine's going on a break
next protein needs to hurry up Sugar's
going on a break cuz sugar needs it oh
my God ah acid protein protein salt get
it in go what do we need oh my God we
got too many of everything
uh okay sugar acid protein protein
we need one more protein cuz protein's
not cooking oh caffeine is not doing
good ah
freak I know I know it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine okay you
need to go you you need a break I need
another protein come on I need another
protein I need another protein I need
another protein I need another protein I
need another protein I need another Pro
there we go get it get it gone yes yes
that counted that
counted oh my God how many new orders
are going to be salt salt salt salt acid
protein done boom done you take a break
you oh man I need more protein h
yes that was
chaotic that was chaotic to a degree I
haven't seen in a
while but that's
okay everything is fine everything is a
okay we did that we cleared that all
good there no
problems anybody else want to speak up
about how great this
is that's
great no really all right fine then
staff bot head
great oh there he is spooky okay so we
don't have many
left I don't think we have any on this
side of the Mask here okay we're good so
I'm throwing that away we got DJ music
man oh my God he
uh
man he don't look so good I don't know
what the deal is but he is not looking
good
uh-huh yippee oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God yeah yeah this is what we
do okay van lightning City we're oops
that's not right we're taking the van to
the
city we're taking the van to lightning
City there it was oh I just had it oh my
God there we
go where is it go away that's too many
of you guys where's the city go away
where's the city where's the Vans no
Vans what are you talking
about oh oh I see okay yeah you got it
no stop
stop that's the one I submitted it
I submitted it I submitted
it no one can question my
submission I submitt
[Music]
it come ask me bro you cannot
handle you cannot face my
[Music]
wrath show me what you
got Freddy's a star we got Gator butt
with Freddy Star
Waves Gator butt with Freddy Star Waves
okay Gator butt with Freddy Star Waves
go away Gator butt with Freddy Star
Waves go
away oh
why what kind of bull is this every
other one's been fine up until this one
I got to do that five times okay I just
I guess I just got to spam it all around
me because there's no way that I'm going
to be able to pay attention to it hope
you guys like flashing
lights okay we're tanging the van to
Bubble city van to Bubble City Robot
waves van to Bubble
city van to Bubble city van to Bubble
City with
robot Rolling Hills van to Bubble City
stop stop van to Bubble City go that's
the one can't question it that's
it oh yeah baby let me get that
smile I
know Croco butt to the desert mountains
Croco butt to the desert bubble
mountains got it Croco butt to the
desert
bubble Croco butt to the desert bubble
mountains
where is it nope Croco butt to the
desert no there was none of that oh God
go away where is it where are you I hear
you no God damn it I should be able to
intercept them if they're up in the
air this is kind of crazy okay we got go
caring in the desert stars with a
robot go cing in the Desert Star
s with a go carting in the desert
Stars ah freak I've forgotten what it
is okay listen Okay my God go-karting in
the desert Stars I I can't even remember
what it
was go cing in the desert stars with a
robot there is no background whatever my
God cing in the desert stars with a
robot oh my God that was it stars
with nothing that's
it can't say it's
not thank
you all right Checker Mountain stars go
carding in the Checker Mountain
stars go let me do it Go caring in the
Checker Mountain Stars oh my
God
why do I hear them go cing in the
Checker Mountain
Stars that's
it let me see that horrible smile
G I
know uh Pink Checker with pizza okay
Rainbow Mountains pink
Pizza Rainbow Mountains pink pink Pizza
nope Rainbow Mountain Rainbow Mountain
pink
Pizza wait a I forgotten what the
freak was it Rainbow Mountain pink Pizza
Rainbow Mountain pink pizza that's it
Rainbow Mountain forgot about the
rainbows Rainbow Mountain there's none
of this this is it Rainbow Mountain pink
pizza two more of
these oh
thank
you Green Mountain bubbles Green
Mountain bubbles Pizza Green Mountain
bubbles Pizza Green Mountain bubbles
Pizza Green Mountain bubbles Pizza yep I
know come on bam that's it Green
Mountain bubbles
pizza party
party hi
all right last
one crocodile uh lightning mountains
crocodile
robot crocodile lightning lightning
mountains lightning mountains that's it
lightning mountains crocodile robot
that's
one
DJ hey hey I thought for a second
there I thought for a second there you
were going to kill me that would be very
bad of
you hey
yipp ruined DJ music man
oh good that's what you want to
see oh oh wait one second I got to open
this in front of which way did new ones
go I never know I always go the wrong
way there he
is well it's no different than it was
before
oh
wow is that is that Freddy or is that
golden Freddy
Bonk uh okay well that's something I
guess all right I did that which means
there's just one more thing that we must
do we've done all those we've done all
those done all those done all those that
just leaves this this is the last
one and it is the office in Sister
location which is the very most like
Five Nights at Freddy's very fitting
they should be last why the plush babies
I don't like that the plush babies want
to play red light green light shining
the flashlight on them is a red light
the darkness is the green light don't
let them Reach the office right circus
baby wants to play hideand-seek use the
cameras to find every plush baby and
shock them
uhhuh this seems contradictory okay I'm
going to fail a couple times on this but
sure
whatever oh it is dark do I have a light
uhoh it's so dark oh I do have a light
when the lights go out we passed the
time by playing
Mily uhhuh let's play office I will be
the boss you be the
worker for your first task you need to
play Red Light Green Light okay how do I
do
that how do I do that what do I need to
do for that I I don't know what to do
for that oh no no no no no no no you
stay right
there you stay right there stay right
there so there doesn't seem to be
anything wrong with me whoa whoa whoa
whoa
feel bad for you
why why stop there is no going you will
not be able to
go uh-oh that's not good
H you think I can't keep this up you
don't think I got the power huh you
think I can't handle all of this huh you
think that any of you is going to be
able to sneak up on me huh I got the
reflexes of a cat you feel bad for me
feel bad for them they can't move a
muscle I'm too fast I'm faster than
light itself and they ain't getting
closer they ain't not getting clo that's
what I thought well done employee I know
I
know hide and seek uh-huh well that's
too bad for them because check the
cameras yeah I'm real good at this when
you find her give her a controlled shot
oh don't worry about that I'm on it
ready or not
huh where you at where you at where you
at where you at where you at where you
at
oh wait where you at where you
at huh oh got you that's what I
thought you out there again or is it
going to symble me when you are I like
it here it's safe what do you mean safe
forever what do you mean got you can't
hide from me and what do you mean safe
forever are you in here better not be in
here oh oh God up that
dou easy
peasy H you know what's faster than
light lightning it's not but don't they
don't know that just hold
on
freak man this is kind of spooky I don't
know about the darkness gang also the
time doesn't seem to be moving at all
feel bad for you I feel bad for you I
feel bad for you all your little friends
are getting lightning you are a very
hard worker I know I
know so what am I doing like why what is
what does that mean what does that mean
what do you mean in case you didn't know
faster than light where what who where
why who's there what do you mean what's
going on what's the
de
okay kind of overreacted there a little
bit not
today oh I can see you perfectly if I do
that that's almost cheating not today
who H that's what I thought think I saw
you flying through the
ether I feel bad for you oh man maybe
you just feel bad for yourself am I
supposed to be doing this multiples why
is this only on the vent who did that
who who did that what do you mean where
what what's going
on didn't even get to
laugh oh hi bye oh that was another one
where you who thought I saw you oh there
you
are okay this is
ridiculous I feel bad for you uh-huh
why
uh-huh
whoa there's another one here there you
are what
what
no
no I got to go through all that
again oh if only I had two flashlights
listen I was using my left hand I was
holding back the whole time last time
you want to see what it's like when I
really try
you better watch out you better watch
out right about now I don't even need to
look at you to be able to get the other
one oh hi nope didn't think so n not
today why but no oh was that no oh wait
a no oh sorry pal no not today not today
not ever actually never actually oh
what's that do you have another friend
coming right over there oh man I'm sorry
about that oh whoops ah not going
nowhere oh behind the back over the
Shoulder Through the pit bam bam bam oh
no they're not getting any closer
because they can't be stopped by the
Light cash Cas cash bam wham wham wham
wham wham right in the eyes right in the
okay well done employee yeah I
know
so special oh you
know born this
way too handsome for this world you
know that paper's still over there good
job yep you are a very hard worker that
I am okay so I need to pay attention cuz
it was probably behind me and also I'm
going to be silent because their Labs
reveal where they are
you're
it got him sa
forever one two where are you where are
you oh freak where's the other one
where's the other one where's the other
one where what do you mean
oh
okay whoa ah you can be right there huh
okay so that's one one
zero one there's one more some more
there you
are one just one or two two out now
there you go that's another one there's
one
more just
checking it's two that was two of
them that's another one
where I feel like there's one more can't
tell employ yeah
yeah look at the time oh my God oh my
God oh my God wait wait who wait whoa
who what you
this oh what oh my God oh my
God
oh oh oh
man
oh
I H thank you
he thank you thank you very much you are
so
L yeah that was great out yep
oh okay thank
[Music]
you
yeah I did it
oh why you looking at me all sultry you
cupcake stop
it
yay gigantic circus
baby okay so the question is now that
was all of them
right that was
everything hey wait a
minute there's one more hold on let me
find circus
baby
huge way too huge what too big I got
them all
oh I is too
big I is too
big all
right
SK oh
what there your
oh
br oh it's a shadow
BR
bruh oh oh was that always there he's
[Music]
big oh
crap what what I'm in the floor why am I
in the floor I don't think I don't think
I should be in the floor for this oh I'm
not in the floor anymore hug
time oh
God
[Music]
uh-huh uh-huh take a mask take a
mask
hi
it's
fine yeah that's that's a good idea kid
well that was ruined
so I am mask bot formerly known as map
[Music]
bot
okay can I come here come on I've
already seen this I'm not being rude or
anything I'm just trying
to get on with
it get on with it
whoa
floor guys there's
floor what else is there what others
floor yeah that's floor all right look
at this
floor ah what do you think's happened on
this
floor lot of secrets on this floor
it's got swirly does it's a
floor ah no not yet we're looking at the
floor damn look at that
floor feels so real this
floor there's a mystery here it's up to
me to solve the lore of the floor I will
oh I will answer your riddle floor
oh I must have solved it
oh it's kind of weird that that's frozen
in time like that why is this why is
this
occur not going to talk to me huh
celebrate go down and come back up and
go
down replay fast drawn what does that
even
mean oh wait no that's not what I wanted
no I really don't want
that I don't want that I don't want that
right now good we're good thank you all
right well look at that is that's my
well-deserved reward the only other
thing that I have not done as I've not
gotten all the
coins now I don't know if I may be doing
that but let's just
say I can be
convinced I can be convinced that it's
worthy of my time you know what's funny
is I didn't even
see
the whatever the virus rabbit is not
even sure about that okay I can't exit
that
one but either way that was fun I had a
good time I had a great time there's a
few other Mysteries here probably but I
think they did a good job with the mini
games here so that they was actually
interesting across the board there was a
little bit of repetitiveness here and
there uh but all in all I had a good
time sometimes it actually scared me
like legitimately scared me so thank you
everybody so much for watching and
enjoying this wonderful V VR Adventure I
haven't done VR in a bit and I Know It
kind of spread this one out a little bit
but I've been busy I I really have been
so iron lung has been taking over my
life uh but don't worry it's actually
almost done boom boom you want some
lemonade all right I put you in there
hey yippe I'm on a
[Music]
cupcake you think you can bully meof bof
wham
wham cut your
arm I thought I thought it would come
back anyway
um I kind of feel bad about that now
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching have a wonderful day hope you
enjoyed this uh there is technically
more secrets to go but we'll see about
that later but like I said iron lung has
been taken up for my entire life it's
almost done it really is almost done
almost been a year straight now of
effort but it's going to be really worth
it I can't wait for you to see it it's
going to be really fun anyway thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye